bit more on our platform.
And then we can dive a little bit deeper into the nitty gritty and figure out where the best use kits for you guys is right now.
So let me know if you can see my screen here.
So essentially, Ridge is an AI platform that powers smarter data collection so you can build relationships everywhere.
Whether that's someone buying through retail, buying through Amazon or even receiving a gift around the holiday season.
That was something that I was gonna touch on a little bit after, and maybe I can bring it up now.
Is gifting like a big part of the business right now, especially like leading into the holidays, or do you not really have too much oversight on that?
Yeah, at the moment, I don't, I would assume so, given the nature of the products and how many bundles we offer, expensive gifts for sure, but just like face masks.
is a popular product that I imagine a lot of gifting done there, but I don't think gifting is like a language that's been focused on historically and trauma correct me if you guys have more insight there, but yeah, I think traditionally people buy the products themselves.
The only time we went into gifting is during like a mother's day, a father's day, at least so far in our experience with the brand.
And even then we still have a hunch that people are buying it mostly for themselves except for the product red light, which is a red light hat.
Like we can see that like women are buying that for men.
But like the face mask we don't think is a gifting excuse.
I wouldn't say it's like a common path.
Okay.
And I guess the reason why I'm asking that because the whole purpose of bridge, and of course, as we expand deeper into what exactly it is, we do, it's to capture customers wherever they may be.
So when we're looking at products that can be gifted, you'll never know who that person ends up being.
So by utilizing, you know, bridge, we're able to help you capture those folks at any point that someone makes, you know, contact with your product.
So that's kind of why I just asked about the whole gift and a part of things.
So you're muted.
I don't know if you were just agree, but yeah.
Okay.
All right.
Cool.
So essentially bridge right now we are working with over 160, you know, top global brand.
So, you know, you have your conglomerates in the world, the Skull Candies, the Heineken's, the Chobanes.
And let me see here.
I dive a little bit deeper.
So essentially everywhere your customers are, we can be too with bridge.
So
Taking a look here, we can empower you guys via digital wings on your socials, packaging displays, and then in real life as well.
So if you are running events, we're able to really show
where your product lives and be able to present to ourselves as you expand out on events, but given you don't really oversee that, we can save that part of the conversation for some other folks on your team as well.
And if you can dream it, bridge can power it.
So these are a ton of our use cases, obviously not all of them make a ton of sense for you guys, but a few areas where I do see this resonating would be product education
reviews, warranty registrations, and then maybe some like early access for some new products coming down the line.
Right.
So few of our use cases here where we're really empowering our brand.
So submitting reviews, being in the wellness space,
reviews mean everything whenever I'm buying a new product like a red like maps, for example, I'm always scouring the internet for reviews and seeing, you know, what other folks are thinking.
You know, event activation sweepstakes, influencer channels, which is a route that you were talking to as well.
And then education, right?
You're using a new mask.
How do I use it?
How long do I use it for being able to empower folks to have that sort of education at the palm of their hands?
is obviously super important.
So I'll kind of stop there really quickly.
I know I kind of just ran through a few slides.
So if you have any questions so far, feel free to, feel free to ask away.
No questions, but the review section was pretty cool.
I definitely think, you know, I need tools and can leverage to facilitate more reviews from our customers, you know, will be helpful.
And I believe you mentioned contact career partnerships as well with Bridge.
I'll ever do that.
Yeah.
Talk to me a little bit about your review capture right now.
What are you, what are you guys currently doing along that front?
I'd love to hear more than you.
We probably claim you, um, segmentations to push for reviews.
Uh, don't know if we're leveraging any QR codes, um, or the channels or like tools we're using for, to generate reviews.
Um, on the website, but I do know they positioned them well, uh, and leverage them in a content, but as far as just like getting exposure to more reviews, I don't know if there's like a outside of this, like, sitting play, or attending
SMS messages, I'm not sure if there's a very conscious effort there, but again, Charlotte brands, if you guys know, any insights there, or if you've run any specific campaigns, then, well, if you're not.
No.
Not exactly yet, but I'm really excited to see what's possible and what you guys have to switch your tests to.
Yeah, yeah, absolutely.
Let me see.
I'm going to pull up an experience that we actually built for you guys so you can see what it looks like in the wild through QR activation.
And if you guys don't have QR codes on your packaging right now, we can make these work via a digital link as well.
So you'd be able to plug those into your social channels.
Jordan, give your phone out by any chance of your phone on you or if you scan this QR code, I can make it a little bit bigger too.
It doesn't work.
I can just I could just pull it right up.
Don't worry.
There you go.
It's a couple tries to get it to click.
But now I've got to pull that now.
All right, cool.
So these are, essentially, these are our bridge experiences.
And this is how we really empower brands to start collecting that first party data.
So since we're integrated with Shopify, we can extract all of your assets directly from there.
So imaging in video, you don't have to go out and start recreating anything for your products.
We can actually go in there and just do a simple API integration.
We can drag and drop and build these out.
I'll show you the backend.
Probably not on this call.
We'll probably have to schedule a second call to dive into the actual back end of the platform, but to show you how we could bring your brand to life.
This is again, what those bridge experiences would look like.
So right now, the call to action that we've put in a place that we believe would make a ton of sense for your products would be like registering your product.
So you'd click here, you'd activate, and then we'd collect email from there.
But we can build out these flows, however you want to.
We can get extremely creative here.
So aside from just registering your product for that warranty activation, we're able to shop directly from a bridge experience and then buy accessories.
You can really put out whatever sort of products you want.
That education component, right?
So learning more about the brand, if we want to tailor these out specifically to products, we can educate folks there.
bulking a treatment, but then also that review section building out the flow there so we can drive more reviews for either the brand or the individual products depending on what you guys need.
I'll kind of stop there.
See if you have any questions so far.
No, I like the flow of this.
I think definitely we can attach it to packaging and it would be a great experience.
And just like getting more people dry, especially like the book of treatment for those that are close to the spot or bought locally and being able to, I guess, find other solutions or book at the local spot they were on yet.
And then the shop now experience.
I guess how are you guys tracking this?
Do you have a tool for measuring?
Do you guys have analytics?
Are you kind of past long UTMs and allow the measurement tools we use to track the sales driven premise from Bridge?
Yeah, so I guess I can jump in here to kind of answer a couple of those.
So, absolutely.
So how we're tracking it is like any data collected in Bridge gets passed through real time to both Shopify and Clavio.
So we actually create a profile in Shopify for anyone that we're capturing.
So what's going to happen is let's say I buy a higher dose mat on Amazon.
I register the products.
I'm going to be in your systems.
Your team's going to be sending me or Shama really is going to be sending me like probably great retention marketing flows and different things like that.
I might eventually convert and buy those accessories on your Shopify site.
We can actually tag that revenue.
So we can start to track what we consider like offline to online revenue through the air.
So you can see like the general traffic on.
any of these bridge experiences or pages, but we also with that deep Shopify Clavio integration can see like, wow, it actually matters that we're connecting with our quote unquote offline or unknown customers, because now we're seeing in three months they tend to spend 300 more dollars or whatever the case is there.
Yeah, on the revenue piece.
And then on the meta piece and Sharma team, this is actually new since we've last spoken.
And I probably owe you like a lot more enablement around this, but we now are rolling out functionality with meta on the channel ads.
So this is a really cool way for your team to start to get credit of like, you pushed me an ad, but I didn't check out from your Shopify site.
I both is at Nordstrom.
But because I registered the product, we can actually tie that profile together.
So you can see like the meta ad did work.
I just ended up buying an offline scenario.
So I think also like that's a really interesting connection point and play for you all.
It just takes those meta dollars a lot further and you could start to see the value of like, okay, we are reaching people.
They're just not purchasing on that D to C flow.
That's really cool.
And then you're not a curiosity there.
Do you know who or who to where to those like meta dollars or meta ad spend kind of live through on your team currently?
Because I know you guys are running 88 campaigns and I know that they're not cheap by any means, but would love to hear a little bit there if you like.
We're investing in product.
No, like, who's responsible for running those, those meta ads or yeah.
Okay, you're doing on that.
Okay, fantastic.
Yeah.
So we run all like pans on keyboard of the D to C support.
So it can be meta to talk, Apple and Google Pinterest.
And then we don't touch Amazon.
That's sort of our collaboration.
That's fair.
And Jordan is like overseeing it all.
I'm like experiential channels.
Yeah.
So I would say like Jordan, I want to kind of tie this all together for you.
So I think like the registering your product play is like a
I'm going to say, like, brain dead use case for you guys for post-purchase capture.
Like, I think this will help you know your customer so much better.
It's going to drive up retention, connecting people, et cetera.
But I also heard you say, like, you're really focused on top of funnel growth as well.
Like, how are you going to, like, help drive that?
I think the meta component, this will help you see kind of the tail end of, like, add dollar spent who and where people are converting.
I think the other things that we've seen folks take advantage of from a bridge perspective is any sort of like place you're showing up whether it's a direct mail campaign or just like top of funnel and digital strategies, sending people to a bridge experience can capture their email even if they're not ready to purchase and then your team can nurture them post email capture.
So we see some folks like build a bridge experience and that call to action will be like
unlock your wellness guide from higher dose.
That might not be a higher dose customer yet, but they're interested in that content exchange.
We're going to capture email because it's the one click email capture.
Then you get to nurture them and kind of help them and not nudging them to purchase flow.
So
The point here is like, we're definitely a platform and you can kind of like pull all these different use cases.
So I want to be clear, like, I think the registry or product is incredible for like this post purchase, know your customer, nurture them.
But I think being able to tie that into some of your brand awareness, like pre-purchase campaigns becomes really interesting.
And then we like layer in the meta component.
So all those dollars go further.
Yeah, no, I appreciate you giving that example definitely connects a few more dots on how we can leverage this.
For top of funnel channel extension, especially, I mean, register your product and be able to track retail sales.
It's just like another layer for attribution, which will be super helpful in measuring the impact of a channel like meta or TikTok as well.
Stuff that it may not have or campaigns that may not have that
linear path to conversions and attribution, you can still see there's lift in other ways.
We are bringing out additional tools to track that, but that is pretty interesting.
Another thing that we didn't touch on, and I know we just have two minutes, but Jordan, what's your guys' philosophy or policy on discounting?
Do you guys do discounting today?
So I know we're moving away from being a discount heavy brand.
That's been like a huge focus in years as well, which is
Also been a struggle just for, you know, going into the ecosystems of these paid channels without having being able to leverage those discounts, you can see the impact on conversion rates.
So I won't say you're like, there are opportunities for us to push sales and, you know, have discounts, but it's not going to be a primary focus, like we didn't run up for the July campaign this year, which also I don't believe we ran it last year, but it's just kind of moving away from that and
being more of a premium brand positioning.
Yeah, do people shop every day?
And the welcome offer just to anchor that is 10%.
So it is a very, like, that shows sort of the philosophy.
Yeah, that's actually helpful because what we've seen some of our customers do that I think are in a very similar position to you.
They're not giving a 20, 30, 40% off is we also support rebates, which people primarily use for in-store purchase.
So it's a different
discount motion.
It's like, you have to opt into a rebate, then go purchase the product and upload your receipt.
The consumer gets a Venmo back.
So some people will do it very specifically of like, we want to make a huge splash because we're launching in Target.
Hey, if you go up into this rebate and then buy and store up what you receive, you'll give them a back of $20.
But we see it as like top of funnel acquisition.
People opt in a lot to the rebate, but your discounting is much lower of like who's actually getting off their couch and going to purchase.
But that can be an alternative way that folks have approached getting away from these like big, big discounts, but more so like a cashback component.
That's awesome, especially, you know, being able to use the peer-to-peer money transfer platforms, like let people get that back a little bit quicker and instantly, so that's cool.
Yeah, it's just a different psychology play.
Like, they're still spending that like two, $300 amount, but then they have that like $20 in their Venmo account, which people love.
Yeah, not for sure.
And I guess how does that tech work or how does that play into what would you need for the brand to be able to execute something like that?
Yeah, so basically you all would set the offer type and then you build it in the bridge platform, which is like the no code builder, and then you all decide how you want to do the distribution.
So I'm sure like the Sharma team would help with that.
A lot of folks just push that through a meta ad.
And then we facilitate everything into end the data collection, the receipt validation and the payouts.
So it's a pretty white glove service on our side.
Yeah.
No, go ahead.
Go ahead.
Where I think it could get tricky just currently.
There's no matter ad spend supporting retail.
And so I think that is a big business decision.
There's also no matter ad spend like that supported prime, for example, like meta and the paid budgets that we are handed at least on our side are strictly to drive to the D to C. So I think that would probably need a pivot in
strategy or experiential budget because the offline sales aren't
traced, which, to your point, could be really powerful, but they're also not incentivized from the, the paycheck.
Gotcha.
That makes sense.
Yeah.
I mean, it's a really good point.
I think like some people run them without the paid.
Obviously, there's less eyeballs there, less, like a Nordstrom specific micro influence arc, which honestly works.
But anyways, I know we're also over time.
So, Guy, let me kick it over to you for next steps.
Yeah, Jordan, I was just going to say obviously there's a lot to unpack here.
What I would love to do is find some time for us to chat next.
I want to take you through the actual back end of the platform and show you how to actually build out these experiences because we can get extremely creative with them and soak in your team.
But it can get a little complicated, and it's better to actually see how they're built out.
And then also showing you the full back end of the platform.
So showing you all that tracking, where all the data lives, and how we can pass all that over to you.
Again, it's just going to take a little bit more time for me to show you all of that information.
So I wanted to see if you had some time like mid next week for us to reconvene and pick back up on the conversation.
Yeah, Wednesday, Thursday, or Tuesday, Wednesday, that's more simple for a midweek check-in.
We can do then.
I would say Tuesday is a little bit more availability.
Are you also based in New York City?
No, I'm in Boston.
Okay, cool, cool.
So it's still just in time.
I'm central or I will be central then too.
So cool.
I could do either next Tuesday after like
2 p.m.
or Wednesday is pretty open.
Anything after 2 p.m.
on Wednesday is pretty good for me.
We can go 2 30 on Tuesday.
Actually, no, let me.
Is there is an ignorant.
Ingrid is out on till Tuesday, I believe, and I do want to like Ram robin with her as well prior to speaking again.
So if we could do Wednesday and what are your times Wednesday?
Yeah, no, I could do Wednesday.
You want to do same time 2 30 Eastern?
Is that what you were?
That one might be a little bit of a screen.
Yeah, let me see.
Do you have anything?
Yeah, I could do one Eastern.
Does that work?
Yeah, that would work.
All right, cool.
I'll shoot out an invite for you.
And then let me tie up an email kind of going over everything we talked about, but pretty much for the next call, we'll look to go into the back end of the platform.
And again, I'll just show you.
how to build them out.
It's super easy, but then showing me the back end to the platform too, so you can see where we track everything.
But I'll summarize everything in an email and get it off to you in the next couple of hours or so.
All right.
Sounds good.
Awesome.
Appreciate it.
Thanks for everybody.
Great to see you all.
Happy Friday.
See you.
I think the tool's valuable.
It feels like we're not strong.
All right.
What do you think I did it?
Oh, that was a good deal.
Yes, our own insurance, and you can only have one primary provided.